et après ce départ des soldats français
de ce que l'on a appelé la zone
humanitaire sur les autorités zaïroise
ont décidé de fermer leur frontière avec
le rwanda pour éviter un nouvel afflux
de réfugiés certains d'entre eux essaie
malgré tout de passer en se jetant dans
la rivière qui marque la frontière entre
les deux pays
isabelle des fleurs jamais la frontière
rwando zaïroise n'avait été aussi bondée
plus le départ des derniers soldats
français de turquoise approchait plus la
quête de sécurité désespérée des vous
tous venez s'agglutiner sur le pont deux
cas vous c'est le moment que les aéro
ont choisi pour fermer leurs portes
l'engorgement est instantané ils
attachent les légionnaires français
postés à la frontière bien difficile
mais ils n'ont pas le choix
un mois de 24 heures de leur départ ils
sont confrontés aux pleurs au désespoir
à la douleur aveugle et d'erwan dès
qu'ils veulent sur leur pays
inquiétude des agents des nations unies
sur le terrain au hcr nous préférons que
les frontières restent ouvertes pour que
les réfugiés puissent fuir quand ils se
sentent menacés même si cette menace
pedneault paraît pas justifié désormais
tous les moyens sont bons pour passer la
panique des rwandais point c'est dans ce
cul de sac de xingu au bord du lac kivu
les a littéralement jeté à l'eau ce
jeune homme qui ne lâche
qu'approximativement est emporté par le
courant
pour lui la riviéroise s'éloigne et
l'espoir aussi il ne devra la vie qu'à
la gold lui tend un légionnaire français
le pire peut-être que la fermeture de
cette frontière a coupé en deux bien des
familles rwandaises en effet un bon
tiers des piétons qui empruntent elles
font étaient des réfugiés en quête de
nourriture de bois de chauffe ils sont
irrémédiablement bloqué au rwanda à deux
km à vol d'oiseau des leurs réfugiée à
bukavu